[Music]
a powerful 7.2 magnitude earthquake has
struck haiti prompting a red alert from
the u.s geological survey for what it
expects will be many casualties
buildings have collapsed and a number of
deaths have been reported the epicenter
was about
160 kilometers west of the capital porto
prince the disaster plague nation is
still recovering from the earthquake in
2010 that killed more than 200 thousand
people
let's cross live to heidi joe castro in
washington d.c so hi to adi tell us what
we know what more we know about this at
the moment
well hasn't we know that this quake
struck at about 8 30 local time in the
morning in haiti that was about two and
a half hours ago and the country's new
prime minister
ariel henry has confirmed that there are
deaths though the official numbers
may still take a while to come in due to
the communication breakdown that's part
of the destruction here the u.s
geological survey has issued a red alert
for the likelihood of high fatalities
saying that the high casualties are
probable and that the damage is
widespread
now of course this couldn't come
at a worse time
for the worst circumstances haiti is
still struggling to recover
from the magnitude 7.0 earthquake that
hit in 2010 which was smaller than the
7.2 magnitude measured this morning that
earthquake of course leaving close to
300 000 haitians dead destroying homes
for 1. 1.5 million now we're seeing
images from social media of crumbled
buildings of hospitals that have been
devastated others overwhelmed with a
number of people streaming in
with injuries and of course haiti is
still over going through its political
crisis after the assassination of its
president just five weeks ago
indeed all this coming at a time when
the country is already reeling from all
of the problems that you just uh
outlined there heidi joe castro we'll
check in with you again uh hopefully
when we get uh more information for the
moment heidi joe castro live for us
there in washington dc well john bellini
is a geophysicist at the u.s geological
survey's national earthquake information
center he joins us now from golden in
colorado thanks very much for being with
us uh now i know your your team has been
monitoring um this quake tell us what
you know about at this
point well what we know is that we have
a magnitude 7.2 uh for this earthquake
and it is located um
west of port-au-prince uh farther west
actually than the january 2010
earthquake which was a little bit
smaller at a magnitude 7.0
so uh that is definitely a positive
thing with this but because of the size
and population density there will
probably be widespread damage
and what sort of damage i know
information is sketchy at the moment and
and this this may be a little
speculative but
give us a sense of of the kind of damage
that an earthquake like this on this
magnitude could do in a country like
uh haiti
where the infrastructure is already not
particularly strong and as we said at
the top there the country is still
recovering from that
devastating earthquake of 2010.
based on what we saw with the 2010
earthquake we would not be surprised to
see lots of
uh buildings collapsed um and hav others
having uh quite a bit of significant
damage
and how long would it take for
uh
you know to fully assess
uh the kind of damage that would be done
after after a a quake like this
well we don't do damage assessments
directly but um you know because of the
location and
uh the nature of this the situation
there uh damage assessments you know
something that's going to take some time
good to speak with you
uh john bellini thanks very much for
being with us